this video is sponsored by formation
if you're a junior or mid-level engineer
who wants to land a job at a fan-level
company then stick around to hear more
about the formations program or learn
more at the link in the description box
about a year after graduating from
college i decided to move from my
hometown of san diego california to the
san francisco bay area aka the hollywood
of the tech industry it would be my
first time living outside of southern
california as an adult and so naturally
i was really excited and curious as to
what life might be like in the bay after
all it was home to many great things
like pixar apple the gay rights movement
good sourdough bread and was also where
my husband scott grew up but especially
being a software engineer i knew that
this is where the tech industry was born
and continued to thrive and just more
than anything i wanted to know what the
whole fuss was about i heard it was one
of the best places to grow your tech
career and that there was nowhere else
in the world like it and so with my
husband scott and her dog kona we moved
to a spot that was five to 15 minutes
away from the facebook google apple and
netflix headquarters and we lived there
for about five years during my time
there i worked at three different jobs
learned to use the cow train for my
commute found every coffee shop in soma
started my youtube channel forged
lifetime friendships hiked gorgeous
landscapes unique to the area got
married spent time with my in-laws ate a
lot of really really great food and
worked a lot but living in the bay
wasn't exactly a breeze either the rent
prices were some of the highest in the
country which meant that we could never
move out of a rent-controlled home and
because the tech industry had created
large income disparities especially
within the local community
we were reminded of those negative
impacts daily and this is more of a
first world problem but because all of
our friends who worked in tech were
always really motivated and career
driven and therefore busy we often
scheduled our hangouts more than a month
in advance which usually meant that we
would drive an hour each way to get up
to the city just to chill luckily both
my husband and i had tech salaries and
so we were privileged enough to have a
lot of options and opportunities but it
didn't sit super well with us that even
those that were born and bred there
didn't have the same options to live and
thrive in the bay area so sure our
careers took off and we had a lot of
happy moments but we knew that there was
someplace else that aligned more with
their lifestyle and vibe overall to make
us happier so in 2020 when the pandemic
hit we decided to move back to san diego
in fact my husband actually always
wanted to stay in san diego so the fact
that he came up and lived with me up
there for five years is something that i
will always love him for so thank you
scotty so we bought our house at a
fraction of the price of a comparable
home in the bay area and moved out of
silicon valley i made a video a few
months after the move about how it felt
to leave the bay and what noticeable
changes there were in my attitude and
lifestyle i'm absolutely happier having
made the move and i'm glad that i both
spent time in the bay and also that i
don't live there anymore but if i were
to start my career today in tech would
it be the best idea to move to silicon
valley or more broadly the san francisco
bay area or are there other cities that
are better to move to in this
post-pandemic remote work culture world
what is it even about the bay area that
makes it such an important place for
technology i mean how do i even start
there to begin with these questions have
been rattling in my head as i approach
the two-year mark of moving out so i
decided to look into it i looked into
the history and culture of silicon
valley how it's changed in relation to
the pandemic and whether it's still the
best place to move to for a tech career
the san francisco bay area has a rich
history originally settled by the ohlone
people it was a part of spain then
mexico then became a part of the united
states in 1848 literally the year after
the gold rush which picked in 1849
brought about 300 000 new people from
across the states and abroad to
california all hoping to strike gold
this brought a ton of wealth to the area
and many iconically bay area things like
wells fargo stanford university
victorian houses and golden gate park
were created during this time the area
continued to evolve even after a
devastating earthquake in 1906 which
left much of the city in ruins the city
rebuilt quickly and withstood the great
depression built the golden gate bridge
and became an important military hub
during world war ii now after the war
while san francisco became home to the
hippie and counterculture movement and
the gay rights movement the tech
industry was having its early beginnings
in the city of palo alto about 30
minutes south of san francisco palo alto
is the home of stanford university whose
provost at the time was a man named
frederick turman he was a leader in
research for vacuum tubes circuits and
instrumentation which served as a basis
for much of the technology in radio tv
telephones and early computers he even
had a hand in the founding of
hewlett-packard whose founders were both
students of his and during his time as
dean he encouraged the university's
faculty and alumni to start their own
companies which marks the beginnings of
the entrepreneurial spirit of silicon
valley around the same time a man named
william shockley was inventing the
transistor and moved to mountain view
california the town right next to palo
alto to found shockley semiconductor
labs which worked on the first silicon
semiconductor devices which gave silicon
valley its name he went on to receive a
nobel prize in physics which apparently
made him so inflated with ego that he
became incredibly difficult to work with
in fact it gave birth to a group of
folks called the traitorous eight who
left shockley semiconductor to form
fairchild semiconductor they were the
ones that really established the bay
area as the home for silicon
semiconductors even though other cities
like boston camden and new york had far
more active transistor companies than
the bay after the success of fairchild
many other founders and former employees
went on to invest in companies that hit
big in fact a study found that 70 of the
valley's public firms can be traced back
to fairchild semiconductor and their
combined value represented more than 2.1
trillion dollars at the time of the
study of course this starts to bring us
to the modern day beginnings of the tech
industry as we know it the dot-com era
saw the creation of companies like
amazon yahoo ebay netscape geocities and
more and then it crashed in 2000 which
really led to our current era of
technology
so what is modern day silicon valley
like now well when we look at the
geography of the san francisco bay area
there's actually five distinct counties
that make up the region
marin county alameda county san mateo
county santa clara county and san
francisco county and of course that
giant bay right in the middle of it all
with mountain ranges bordering each now
i think each county has a really unique
vibe to it which really just makes the
bay area all that more special depending
on your lifestyle there's kind of
something for everyone in the bay so
long as you can afford it the first of
course is san francisco county which
only has the city of san francisco in it
which is seven miles long and seven
miles wide all the neighborhoods have
something different to offer and is the
best place in the bay to get that city
urban living feel marin county includes
some of the most beautiful nature in the
bay which means that it also comes at a
high cost it's also not the most
accessible part of the bay so not many
tech folks move there unless they're
right across the water from san
francisco alameda county is basically
the east bay area it's got famous cities
like oakland and berkeley and has a more
counter culture vibe to it than other
parts of the bay area san mateo county
is the peninsula which is bordered by
the bay itself and the mountains to the
west many folks who live here tend to be
families with the parents commuter
either north to san francisco or south
to the south bay for their tech jobs and
then there's santa clara county which to
me is considered the heart of silicon
valley driving around you'll feel how
techy this area is as you see names of
big tech companies on their buildings
like facebook netflix google intel and
more but because the tech industry isn't
just about silicon or semiconductors
anymore and it's more about like digital
products and services
a lot of people tech companies employees
have moved northwards to san francisco
because a lot of them are looking for a
vibrant city life so the term silicon
valley these days to me is more
synonymous with the san francisco bay
area since it's more than just the south
bay area now and while the ubiquity of
tech varies depending on which part of
the bay you go to it definitely has a
huge presence there it's not uncommon to
overhear conversations about the
greatest technology or what companies
have ipo or what the work culture is
like at companies and when you go to a
bar in san francisco you're really
likely to bump into a lot of young tech
folks who move from elsewhere so it's
kind of like another version of the gold
rush for california but is it still the
case that it's the best place to go for
a career in technology sure the bay
areas had a rich history of constant
reinvention being on the bleeding edge
of challenging the status quo and thus
became the birthplace of many
technologies and companies that
redefined how we all interact with
computing
but also a lot of people are leaving the
area saw a dramatic decrease in their
population with the pandemic with san
francisco seeing a 6.7 drop the second
biggest drop in the country at the time
behind new york city these statistics
and analyses from a high level are
really helpful to get an idea of the
history and culture and trends that are
happening but i also wanted to get like
a ground level view of what's going on i
interviewed a bunch of people both who
live in the bay who've left the bay and
never considered moving to the bay to
begin with i've asked them all about
their reasons for their decisions on
where to live as well as their thoughts
about how things are changing for
silicon valley so why did these folks
move to the bay the biggest draw for me
to go to silicon valley was the
opportunities all the jobs were down
here first thing you notice is the sun
it seemed to me like something was
happening in san francisco you want to
be queer in some place like
you know san francisco is it so yes it's
definitely the wealth of opportunities
and the weather that draws a lot of
people in as far as the weather goes
which depending on which part of the bay
you're in because there's like a lot of
microclimates and stuff like that year
round is between 40 and 90 degrees
fahrenheit and no it doesn't snow and
there really are more opportunities in
the bay in the first three months of
2021 69 billion dollars of u.s based
venture funds that invest in startups
invested over a third in companies based
in the bay area which is a far larger
slice than any other city in the u.s so
one way to interpret this is the more
startups there are the more jobs there
are for you which means more
opportunities in tech and separately
from job opportunities the culture of
the tech industry in the bay area is
unlike any other back when i was working
there in 2015 2016 every meetup you
could imagine on every kind of
technology was happening all the time so
after work you could go to a meet up and
you could meet a startup founder who was
looking to hire someone just like you
and had the coolest idea like i remember
as a young ios developer i went to an
ios meetup and i was approached by
someone who was starting a company that
was doing
subtitles and conversations for hard of
hearing and deaf folks to better be able
to communicate with their friends and
family and i was like
awesome there is places out there that
are like hacker clubs and stuff and
everywhere you go no matter what day of
the week there will be some sort of mini
conference for your type of engineering
whether that's payments or front end or
something like that you can get
constantly educated in the non-stop
highest tech stuff well i have this
belief that the most valuable thing we
can possibly do at work is create
connections to other people i think
that's literally how a company generates
value and i also think it's really what
gives people the most satisfaction i
think it's possible to connect with
people
over video
but i don't think it's as easy
and i also think that there's nothing
quite like sharing a coffee or beer or
meal with someone because we're talking
about a large amount of money and it
really is about building relationships
even now being there in person kind of
matters like building relationships with
these different companies with these
different investors that matters and
it's mattering less now that we can talk
like this over zoom but it still matters
right partly because it's a cultural
thing and the and the cultural changes
are always going to lag you know
technology's ability for us to connect
and communicate as great as zoom is it's
always better to meet in person so like
to build those relationships to like
make those deals that's why it's there
right but of course the ubiquity of tech
and the types of people that come to the
bay for that reason expresses itself in
many ways sometimes in positives
i still think there's something utopian
about the bay area you know even the
architecture that new salesforce tower
it just it looks like a spaceship to me
and i love that in my neighborhood there
are all these self-driving cars you know
sometimes without people in the front
seat i feel like whatever's happening
here right now
is going to be happening everywhere in a
couple years i do think that because
this life of the city and and technology
are so intertwined
these things get
get merged together like you know san
francisco had these rental scooters
before anyone else did because the
rental scooter company started in san
francisco and sometimes in negatives
this happened in 2010 i was down for
some interviews the interviews were on
friday and i stayed for the weekend i
hung out with some friends we drove up
to yosemite and then came back late
saturday night it was just a day trip my
friend drops me off at one of the
caltrain stations up in san francisco
riding the train south it's like 12 30
in the morning and i'm thinking about
what a lovely day i had and i'm vaguely
listening to all the chatter around me
i'm overhearing these little bits of
conversations and it's all like
my billion dollar idea is this oh well
i'm working at a startup blah blah blah
we're working on this oh my startup is
in stealth mode
it's 12 30
am
on sunday morning and that's what these
people have to talk about actually this
might have been my first real trip down
there
and so it really it really made an
impression of just like get a life if
that's really all you're thinking about
all the time on the one hand
mad respect
like that's why lots of great companies
get founded down there but to me that
just feels like really out of balance
and doesn't feel like a good way to set
up my life so i was riding a tech bus so
um in silicon valley there are a lot of
people who live in san francisco who
want to commute down to the valley and
they don't have cars and so they run
these buses back and forth and at the
time the traffic was so bad that it was
an hour and a half sometimes two hours
each direction so i was spending
10 hours a week on a bus i would be on
the highway and i would look left and
right and it was all buses like we were
running our own train like you look at
like the metro or the subway and it felt
like that but just tech buses and stop
and go traffic homogenous i was meeting
everybody was the exact same that
everyone i met was a software engineer a
product manager or a ceo of their own
startup or trying to hire me or whatever
and i was having the same conversation
with everybody that i met and because
these well-paid tech employees are
really common in silicon valley there's
definitely this kind of constant
pressure that you always want to be
needing more stuff like whether that's
more money or more shares in a company
or more space or a bigger house this is
the trouble
when you live in an environment where
where a lot of people are wealthy is you
start thinking that that is how everyone
lives and you start becoming
dissatisfied with your you know meager 3
000 square foot house silicon valley if
you're not making a million plus bucks a
year you probably look around and you
think oh i live in a scruffy house and
blah blah blah right you lose all
perspective that the median american
family like makes as a household
something like 75 000 per year i think
that is the part that is really hard to
deal with in a place like silicon valley
is because you find that your happiness
on this hedonic treadmill is constantly
drifting as human standards of living
just raise greatly so there's a lot of
pros and cons to life in the bay area
depending on what you're looking for but
with the rise of remote work culture as
a result of the pandemic and the exodus
out of the san francisco bay area
what's changed about life in the bay
before we move on i want to take a
moment to thank the sponsor of today's
video formation if you're an engineer
with one to two years of experience
looking to land top tier roles at
companies like facebook google lyft
airbnb and twitch then you should
definitely check out the formation
fellowship it was founded by staff level
engineers from facebook and nextdoor who
interviewed thousands of candidates and
wanted to create a better way to prep
engineers to perform the best they can
once you apply and get accepted into
their three to six month program you get
a training plan that's personalized to
your specific skill gap with direct
mentorship from super senior engineers
and you can also get referred directly
into top companies in the industry you
can do it part time and they also offer
an income share option so you can pay
zero until you get the job you can check
out their program and apply for free at
formation.dev myuco also linked in the
description box thank you information
for sponsoring now let's get back to the
video
so one of the reasons to be in the bay
before the pandemic was because it quite
literally was the place where it all
happened meetups conferences coffee
walks with your coworkers meeting random
company founders at random public places
but what about now how has remote work
actually impacted the culture in silicon
valley i think a big part of the
pandemic accelerating people's movement
throughout america has to do with that
acceptance of remote work as maybe a
lifestyle and not just a once a once a
week sort of choice people are moving
out most of the friends i talked to that
are moving away part of it is to buy the
freedom that i bought by choosing not to
move to silicon valley which is the
freedom eventually to maybe choose
different to work for different
companies maybe to choose not to even
have to work for a tech company at some
point some people i think move away
because for once people are voting with
their feet when it comes to the type of
city they want to live in people are
asking for more flexibility with hours
sometimes there's you know schooling
issues or kid raising issues or a class
that's going remote for a while or they
get covered for a while or like whatever
happens there's just more reasons to
sort of require flexibility a lot of the
bigger companies have said like they're
never going to go full back to the
office like people at slack i see a lot
of adjustment happening which is always
going to be somewhat painful and the new
normal hasn't quite sunk in yet here
every single company says remote first
or remote only and i think even if ceos
and stuff want to bring back tech to the
office their their employees will just
revolt and they'll just leave and
because programmers have that power they
could just say no i'm not going back and
so i think there's a permanent
fundamental change there i don't think
it's ever really going to go back the
way it was and outside of work what
about life in the city because after all
the city that you work in is also the
city that you live in too san francisco
was sucking there for a little while i
mean i i felt like you know the pandemic
hit us really hard we were one of the
first areas to kind of get hit then you
know we had that summer of uh i believe
it was 2020 where we had the horrible
air quality there was that czu fire
burning uh and the sun literally didn't
come up that september morning i think
that was horrible and i'm a die-hard san
francisco
uh native but
i was like this is sucking i i really
wonder where else i could be
i have to say i started traveling again
once the pandemic lightened up and
you know i it seemed to me like san
francisco sucks and it's terrible but
it's better than anywhere else and like
everywhere else in the world but
especially so in the san francisco bay
area the rising cost of living has been
a huge factor for people to relocate
housing prices is a big thing and
probably like me they're
looking for for a different balance i
don't know how true this is anymore we
actually had an interesting problem or
noticed an interesting pattern like when
i was working at facebook and i was
pretty heavily involved in hiring we
noticed that we basically couldn't get
experienced engineers to move there to
the bay area
we could get college hires to move there
but we couldn't get
experienced engineers to move there not
not necessarily because they didn't want
to or didn't want the job it's because
like let's say you graduated from school
or like you you entered the tech
industry and you went to austin and
maybe you bought a house and it's a nice
house and you've got a nice standard of
living there right and then you get a
job offer at a place like facebook or
google in silicon valley if you sell
your house in austin that's like a down
payment on a house in
in silicon valley and and so your
lifestyle your your quality of life is
going to change
pretty dramatically by virtue of being
in austin for five or ten years you've
now
basically priced yourself out of
moving to silicon valley as a college
student you can move there and share an
apartment with some people and be fine
you're not yet adapted to a higher
standard of living and you're and you
probably don't have you know a partner
maybe kids like who knows whatever right
you can go there and immerse yourself in
that culture and have a great time but
if you're an experienced engineer unless
you're independently wealthy already
because you've you know you've sold a
startup or something like you can't move
there and maintain your same standard of
living so yes the san francisco bay area
has not been immune to the effects of
the pandemic like everywhere else in the
world but with the pandemic starting to
be treated more as an endemic in
california and with in-person
interactions and returns to the office
becoming increasingly more common this
year would it still be a good idea to
move to the bay if you're joining the
tech industry right now
despite what everybody else does on the
internet i try not to prescribe like
overarching generic advice to everyone
because each of you watching are
different you enjoy different things in
life you have different goals you have
different relationships with your family
and friends you come from different
economic situations and you want
different things out of life so to say
that like yes you should move to the bay
area or like no you absolutely should
have moved to the bay area would quite
frankly i think be like unhelpful
because it doesn't take into account all
of who you are but if you are thinking
about moving to the bay area or really
anywhere else for that matter i think
there is a really important factor that
you should think about before making
your decision and that's really to think
about what you want in life and no
pressure if you don't know what you want
in life just yet that's totally fine
just maybe start thinking about it from
different perspectives in terms of your
career do you want to start a tech
startup at some point do you want to
maximize the pure number of
opportunities you'll have in your career
what kinds of companies do you want to
be working at and what kinds of people
do you want to work with and in terms of
your life how do you want to be spending
your nights and weekends how much money
do you want to have left over to spend
after paying rent or mortgage and other
life things what kind of friends do you
want to make and how often do you want
to hang out with them if you have kids
how do you want them to grow up there's
a lot of questions you can ask yourself
to figure out what's important to you
because ultimately designing and
choosing a life that you want plays a
huge part in your overall happiness it's
one of the reasons why people decide to
move at all like i did when i moved back
to san diego like many of my videos the
answer for whether you should move to
the bay area or not is it depends once
you figure out what you want in life and
then think about what level of risk
you're willing to take and what choices
you're comfortable making
then hopefully the answer will become
clearer to you i'll leave you with the
advice of the folks that i interviewed
about whether they think you should move
to the bay my approach has always been
look for opportunities and take them
especially if you're young in your
career don't be too picky about the
opportunities
and don't try to optimize or maximize
all the variables at once because the
biggest thing that comes out of any
experience good or bad is experience and
you know you're going to learn something
from the people that you're around no
matter where you are and the things that
end up really impacting your career are
the things like a great boss a lucky
break in the market something that
changes about like you know the industry
or a migration away from another service
in the u.s service or maybe it's you
know seeing a flaming plane crashing
into the ground as a startup and
surviving maybe that's what you know
really gives you the intuition to to
be successful in the future five years
ago i would have said make sure your
first job was in silicon valley just try
one job there go to all the meetups feel
the buzz be in the center of things but
now i'm not sure i would say that
because everybody's left and there isn't
much of a buzz anymore the different
iterations of san francisco my mom grew
up in like the 60s of san francisco in
the hippie movement and then right after
that like there was the aids epidemic
and like gay san francisco as we know it
and then like class four there was
silicon valley and then there was the
startup scene the tech bus like monopoly
and then
now there's the pandemic and i don't
really know what's gonna happen next but
i think that san francisco continually
reinvents itself like every 20 years and
i'm really really curious to see kind of
what comes after this latest wave and i
think it could be really beautiful i
think i tell someone starting out in
their career
to take a job at a prestigious tech
company that's based in san francisco or
silicon valley and come here and try it
out because i think in you know walking
and just walking to the
off some of these office buildings is
inspiring and exciting and
you may find that it's not for you
but you'll learn things and
be infused with the spirit that you can
take with you i think having kids in san
francisco is a real question that you
need to ask yourself and even having
kids anywhere in the bay area but i do
think that the
somehow the sort of living in the future
trying things and
accelerating it also affects the young
people in san francisco maybe not in the
best way and i don't know if that's
good for kids so i think the calculus
about what you're going to do with your
family is is maybe separate from what
san francisco will do for you and i
think it's part of the reason why a lot
of people move
to sf or the bay area when they're young
and then kind of leave after they get
married and want to start a family if
your goal is to build a tech career it's
absolutely not the only place to go i
think there's a strong argument to be
made for places like seattle and my
advice for somebody who's trying to
build a career is that they shouldn't
just be trying to build a career they
should be trying to build a life and
they should choose based on what they
value
in terms of the whole life that they
want to build you have to pick something
that's going to work for the life that
you want to build and a career is one
part of that there's certainly a lot of
ways to get into tech you don't have to
be in
san francisco to get a job in san
francisco that's number one in fact i
knew a person
who applied to
microsoft just to get a free trip to
seattle and
they will fly you out and they will wine
and dine you you know i think it's very
very hard for me
to say and it's totally true you can
totally not work in san francisco but i
can't get that advice because i think
it's the best place to be if you're in
tech the the pool here is pretty small
so like you're always going to be
working with the same people it's like
going to like college and like you know
there's all this comfort around it but
also like this is the best place to get
the best um information and you're
dealing with all the smartest people if
you're young and you just want to get
really really neck deep into tech you
can only be here it really depends on
your goals of what you want to do if you
want to start a startup these days you
should absolutely move to silicon valley
i imagine it's just like the actor or
actress moving to hollywood you know do
you have to be in hollywood to get into
a movie no but you are near people who
act actors love each other they're all
the same types of people you might get
introduced to other people you might
meet directors this whole thing but then
you think about what is your
typical trope about the actor or actress
who moved to hollywood to make it big
the typical one is not a star is born
and all of a sudden you're lady gaga
singing on some huge television screen
right the the typical person's
stereotype is you are waiting tables
desperately trying to like look better
than the person next to you waiting the
next table right constantly judging
yourself for how much you fall short
complaining about imposter syndrome
right like that is your life is you are
waiting tables
hoping you made it big like lady gaga
comparing yourself to the nearby people
who are doing the exact same thing and
you got to ask yourself like is that the
life i want
happiness that is super important for
people to realize that you know wherever
they move they are buying themselves
into a certain dynamic of what it might
take the average person to be happy
thank you so much for watching today's
video and big thank you to daniel buster
philip kate adam and sean for allowing
me to interview you to learn more about
the topic don't forget to subscribe to
this channel if you'd like more videos
like this one and i'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
you